[Musica]
a quanti di voi sarà capitato di sentire
almeno una volta di non essere in grado
di affrontare una determinata situazione
ora io a me è capitato due minuti fa
prima di salire su questo palco ma
vorrei che ci pensasse un attimo provate
a ricordare quando vi è successo io nel
frattempo prova darvi alcuni spunti non
sentirvi in grado di dichiararvi alla
persona che vi piace io effettivamente
quando era un po più piccola c'era un
ragazzo che mi piaceva tanto non mi sono
mai riuscito a dichiarare anche perché
lui era zac efron quindi c'erano un po
di problemi ma ancora non sentirvi in
grado di partecipare una gara magari
perché gli avversari sono più forti e
voi non vi sentite bravi abbastanza o
ancora un colloquio un test di lavoro
non sentirvi in grado di partecipare ad
un concorso lavorativo perché fallire in
quella determinata circostanza potrebbe
voler dire non essere in grado di
mostrare di non essere in grado di fare
quello che avremmo voluto essere il
lavoro della nostra vita
ora per me prendere una decisione è un
po come lanciare un dado sulle cui
faccio al posto dei numeri ci sono dei
sì e dei no
mentre invece la nostra mano chiusa
prima di lanciarlo quello è il forse ci
sono persone che non si fanno problemi a
lanciare questo dato a prescindere dal
risultato che ne uscirà perché sono
pronti ad accettarlo mentre ce ne sono
altre come invece me che guardano la
l'urbano chiusa e dicono però tutto
sommato non è così male questo forse no
non è un sì ok però non è neanche un no
e questa è una cosa positiva di rail ed
è per questo che gli occhi nato questo
termine che è la confort son del forse è
un termine ancora in lavorazione non è
fantastico però ci sto lavorando
io mi sento di essere una rappresentante
di questo di questa confort non del
forse adesso vi racconto un episodio che
secondo me è molto esplicativo del
perché quando avevo 18 anni video on
line questo concorso al quale per
partecipare bisognava presentare un
progetto e i vincitori 25 in tutta
europa avrebbero potuto vedere il loro
progetto finanziato e le loro idee
portate in un workshop a londra per
imparare come portare avanti appunto
questo progetto
ecco io mi sentivo di stare avendo
l'occasione della mia vita ed era
proprio per questo che io non volevo
partecipare ma non volevo perché per
tutti i motivi che vi ho detto prima non
mi sentivo pronta e gli altri se lo
meritavano più di me e tante altre cose
e alla fine non so come accadde avevo
paura di questo no ma la sera prima
della scadenza così deciso di caricare
comunque la mia partecipazione e alla
fine sorprendentemente la legge
dell'attrazione
in quel caso fu buona con me perché
nonostante tutte le sciagure che mi tra
i addosso pinzi e mi arriva questa mail
della vittoria io ero si contenta che
sembrava una cosa bella ma per me non lo
era perché in quell'occasione io ero
convinta di aver paura di ricevere un no
ma io avevo paura di ricevere qualunque
risultato anche un sì perché poi
sarebbero seguite altre sfide e altre
cose da fare e io non me la sentivo e
quindi preparati da meno in risposta e
scrissi no io mi ritiro grazie poi però
un po di buon senso alla fine non la in
via i
quindi sì vissi una delle esperienze più
belle della mia vita però lo feci come
se fosse uno dei peggiori incubi di
sempre e guardandomi indietro dissi ma
perché l'ho fatto perché mi sono
comportata così e soprattutto mi
riproposi di non comportarmi mai più in
questo modo in relazione a nessun altra
sfida che avrei affrontato da lì in poi
mi presento io sono francesca presentini
ho 24 anni sono una video maker e
illustratrice e lavoro principalmente
online cercando di avvicinare i ragazzi
al mondo dell'illustrazione e negli anni
portando avanti questo mio progetto sono
riuscito ad arrivare ad un bacino di
pubblico di circa 500.000 persone che
per me è fantastico è quello che mi
piace tantissimo del mio lavoro il fatto
che mi metto a contatto con tante per
tante sfide in tanti settori diversi
per dirne una che ho affrontato
recentemente è stata nel settore della
comunicazione quella di spiegare a mia
nonna quale fosse il mio lavoro e è una
sfida ancora in corso devo dire però
sono anche molto fiduciosa sui risultati
ma io lo capisco perché io e tutta la
mia famiglia veniamo da un paese molto
piccolo in toscana che conta 23 mila
abitanti alla fine è la concretizzazione
terrena di quello che io considero
essere il concetto di comfort zone
dentro è tutto piccolo semplice
raggiungibile tutti conoscono tutti e
non succede mai niente di troppo bello
neanche niente di troppo brutto e tutto
facile e per me il mio paese ha sempre
stato il mio piccolo forse però allo
stesso modo io come vi dicevo lavoro sul
web quindi con la comunicazione parlo
tanti ragazzi come me alcuni hanno la
mia età appunto sono miei coetanei e mi
sono resa conto nel tempo di quanto le
nostre esperienze siano per così dire
condivise ovvero un'esperienza che ho
vissuto io
molto probabilmente qualcun'altro l'avrà
vissuta in maniera più o meno analoga
allora mi sono chiesta ma solo io mi
faccio così tanti problemi prima di
approcciarmi a qualunque tipo di sfida
metto un muro di fronte a me prima
ancora di sapere cosa mi aspetterà
e allora ho deciso di rivolgere questa
stessa domanda al web e l'ho fatto nel
modo più classico chiedendo la google e
ho iniziato a digitare perché i giovani
e poi mi sono fermata perché i giovani
si droga non fumano non votano non
capiscono la sostanza del fascismo sono
depressi bevono e ok io qui in realtà
non volevo cercare proprio questo sono
rimasto un attimo scioccato dal
risultato ma ok ho deciso di continuare
a digitare quindi perché i giovani non è
la situazione non è migliorata 15 cani
non votano non capiscono a sé stante il
fascismo di nuovo non trovano lavoro
vabbè non volevo cercare neanche questo
quindi andiamo avanti perché giovani non
hanno niente ne hanno voglia di studiare
ok allora mia discolpa io volevo
soltanto cercare perché i giovani non
hanno fiducia in loro stessi
ma in realtà penso di averlo capito se
cercano queste cose su google come me si
deprimano immediatamente
no sicuramente noi giovani avremo i
nostri problemi se lo chiedete a google
lui potrà fugare ogni vostro dubbio
riguardo avremo ma che io penso che noi
abbiamo anche tante possibilità aperte
basti pensare appunto borse di studio
concorsi accesso alla cultura in questo
preciso istante io potrei rivolgere un
qualunque tipo di domanda il mio
telefono e lui mi risponderebbe in 5
secondi anche se io in questo momento
non ce l'ho in mano ma posso girarmi
urlare ok google
e lui probabilmente mi avrà sentito da
dietro le quinte avere tutte queste
possibilità aperte è fantastico per
tante persone per altre come me è come
vedere tantissime strade da poter
percorrere sapere di poter lanciare il
proprio dato così tante volte e ricevere
un no in cerca in ciascuna di queste
strade
allora io come illustratrice ho provato
a rappresentare questa mia esistenza nel
forse nel facile nel semplice dopo
essermi interrogata su come
rappresentare questo concetto sono
arrivato al risultato che secondo me
somiglia molto a una cosa di questo tipo
semplice linea anni di studi e per
arrivare a questo risultato vede però
direi che io mi riconosco in questo
forse molto lineare per così dire
e tuttavia vincendo questo primo
concorso quindi metà nomi per la prima
volta in gioco e poi dopo quella ne sono
susseguite altre di cose mi sono
trasferito a milano quindi ho lasciato
il mio paesino poi ho dovuto presentarmi
a tante persone diverse ho dovuto
presentarmi a delle case editrici o
pubblicato dei fumetti
ho affrontato cose che inizialmente non
avevo la minima idea che mi sarebbero
mai capitate nella vita e in poco tempo
tutto il mio equilibrio il mio perfetto
mondo lineare la mia linea era esplosa
in una cosa molto più simile a questa se
me l'avessero chiesto prima avrei detto
no grazie no proprio non fa per me però
è a quel punto ho iniziato a dirmi che
tutto sommato mi stava piacendo quello
che stavo vivendo che tutto sommato mi
avrebbe fatto piacere essere più
intraprendente più coraggiosa più
volenterosa di mettermi in gioco e
quindi preso dal panico perché
ovviamente stavo vivendo una situazione
che ancora non riuscivo a capire come ci
fosse finita mi sono sedute ho detto
adesso mi iscrivo una scaletta di cose
che da adesso in poi saranno un po tipo
la cosa che io voglio riuscire ad avere
le linee guida no per per non morire in
tutto quello che sto vivendo e dal
momento che io credo molto nella
condivisione
voglio condividerla con voi proprio
perché spero che possano aiutare qualcun
altro almeno quanto hanno aiutato me
quindi la prima cosa che mi sono scritte
a guardare lontano perché perché quando
avevo 13 anni
io volevo tantissimo diventare un atleta
professionista e vincere le olimpiadi ma
l'unica cosa che riuscivo a vedere di
fronte a me erano le miniolimpiadi che
avrei dovuto vincere di lì a breve per
il quale mi ero preparata per un anno
intero perché anche se io sono molto
piccoli non si direbbe in realtà correvo
molto veloce quindi mi ero qualificata
per i 100 metri piani
quindi il tipo e la pistola spara per la
finale io correvo correvo correvo a un
certo punto sono inciampata ma non tipo
inciampata gambarotta e e addio carriera
sportiva no tipo incespicata su uno
scalino però quella è stato più che
sufficiente per farmi vedere che per me
il mio meglio non era stato abbastanza
non lo era stato in quel momento non lo
sarebbe mai stato e quindi io
abbandonare un po l'idea di percorrere
questa strada che magari non mi avrebbe
portato alle olimpiadi ma mi avrebbe
portato ad apprezzare uno sport che in
realtà io provavo molto divertimento nel
praticare quindi quello che mi sono
segnata e non guardare alla prossima
tappa che affronterai perché si magari
sarà un fallimento ma è soltanto una
tappa di un percorso molto più lungo che
può portarti ad apprezzare per anni o
decenni una disciplina che in realtà ti
piace molto e che sarà forse la
disciplina che pratica rai per tutta la
tua vita
poi mi sono segnata a darsi una scadenza
perché ci sono cose ci sono dati che
vengono tratti in un giorno preciso
indipendente dalla nostra volontà come
per esempio partecipare a un test
lavorativo o appunto presentarsi da un
colloquio o partecipare ad una gara noi
possiamo o partecipare o non partecipare
ma non dipende da noi quella gara accade
comunque ci sono cose che invece
dipendono proprio da noi quando noi
decidiamo
oggi è il giorno e io mi presento o e io
faccio a cadere questa cosa per esempio
anche qui prendendo da uno spunto
personale quando avevo 15 anni
abbandonata quindi la mia carriera
brillante carriera sportiva ho deciso di
intraprendere quella letteraria volevo
diventare una scrittrice
e prepara i quindi mio manoscritto di
500 pagine bellissimo tutto già stampato
in a4 quindi era una roba abbastanza
malloppone stampato sigillato ceralacca
sopra come gli antichi manoscritti ed
ero pronto a mandarlo ad una casa
editrice che adesso non posso menzionare
ma dirò un cognome che è solo un cognome
da mondadori e un cognome non
non ci sono riferimenti comunque ero
pronta a mandarla e devo dire che a
distanza di anni sono fiera di dove sia
finito il mio manoscritto vedi rete in
tutte le mondadori quindi scusate di
nuovo sogno me in tutte le mondadori
d'italia
ve lo mostro è lì sul mio comodino
ancora lì ad attendere di essere spedito
perché perché per me quel giorno non è
mai arrivato io ancora mi ricordavo come
era stato che inciampa nei 100 metri
piani e quindi non volevo assolutamente
sentirmi dire no guardi grazie ma
insomma l'ho scritto non ci interessano
io piuttosto mi immaginavo a 90 anni
sulla mia sedia a rotelle a propulsione
a scrivere il 99º best seller mai
pubblicato ma non perché io non fossi
abbastanza brava per mia scelta che è
molto diverso infine mi sono iscritta a
scusate in realtà volevo soltanto
rimarcare il fatto che era veramente
importante quindi darsi una scadenza
essere il nostro capo essere un po i
datori di lavoro di noi stessi ma non un
datore di lavoro malvagio crudele o
dispotico un datore di lavoro
comprensivo perché d'altronde siamo noi
riteniamo che i nostri progetti vadano a
buon fine quindi appunto l'ultima cosa
che mi sono iscritta è vincere una
vittoria ma perdere che cos'è col tempo
quindi mi sono abituato tenere questo
quadernino che unisca l'utile al
motivazionale da una parte ho iniziato a
scrivere tutte le mie vittorie che non
sono vittorie mastodontiche tipo vinto
ad un concorso sono piccole vittorie
quotidiane come ad esempio oggi mi sono
confrontata con una persona e questo
confronto per me era davvero molto
importante ho saputo gestirlo oppure
oggi ho presentato un lavoro e mi sono
stati fatti dei complimenti per come lo
avevo svolto tante piccole cose che mi
ricordano quando sono stata brava o
fiera di me stessa
dall'altra parte avrei potuto scrivere
cosa ho fatto male però sarebbe stato un
po masochista ricordarmi tutte le cose
che ho fatto male
onestamente chi vorrebbe ricordarsele
allora ho scritto una cosa simile ma un
po diversa ho scritto cosa posso fare
meglio perché si sembra la stessa cosa
ma in realtà è una lista non di
sconfitte ma di opportunità perché fin
tanto che io ho una lista di cosa posso
fare meglio posso rendere sempre più
lunga la lista delle cose che invece
sono stata in grado
fare bene all'inizio di questo discorso
io vi ho chiesto di ricordarvi
un'occasione in cui avete preferito il
vostro forse magari appunto lanciare il
dado e affrontare questa sfida e una
qualunque sfida
quello che posso dire io è che magari il
nostro forse è una situazione di
tranquillità sicuramente è comodo facile
però è soltanto una sensazione
temporanea perché la cosa più brutta che
può accaderti non è lanciare il nostro
dato e ricevere un no e non lanciarlo e
poi a distanza di tempo anni decenni
chiederci cosa sarebbe successo se io
invece quel dato quella volta l'avessi
lanciato perché sì probabilmente noi
nella vita
affronteremo tanti sì tantino tante
risposte che non sono né sì né no ma
sono cose nel mezzo che magari non
avevamo previsto
il punto è che magari ci serviranno
tanti no per un unico grande sì ma
comunque qualunque sia il risultato a
distanza di tempo se è brutto non brucia
così tanto non è così forte come il
giorno in cui l'abbiamo ricevuto mentre
invece un risultato positivo è in grado
di cambiare la nostra vita il nostro
modo di approcciarci al futuro per
questo il mio invito è quello di
lanciare il nostro personale dado più
volte che possiamo sempre con con
entusiasmo e soprattutto con la voglia
di trarne il meglio a prescindere dal
risultato che ne uscirà grazie
[Applauso]